meine Hühner wurden neuerdings in diesem
wunderschönen kleinen Bauwagen
hinstellen und ich gebe euch mal eine
Tür hier hüpfen die Hühner was habe ich
gerade eine Tür gesagt ich meine
natürlich eine Tour also so kommen die
Hühner in den Stall und wir haben eine
elektrische Hühnerklappe die wir mit
Solar betreiben sodass wir am Wochenende
auch mal länger schlafen können und die
Klappe immer automatisch auf uns zugeht
so sieht das Teil aus und das ist eine
Innenseite der Tür montiert und wenn man
einmal um den Stall rumgeht dann sieht
man die Klappe die zu den Legenestern
führt so können wir von außen die Eier
holen ohne jedes Mal in den Stall rein
Klettern zu müssen die Durchlüftung ist
in dem Hühnerstall super wichtig
deswegen haben wir hier ein kleines
Fenster das kann man auch zu machen wir
haben zwei verschiedene Arten von
Sitzstangen damit die Hühner sich
aussuchen können was sie bequemer finden
und Milben vorzubeugen haben wir jede
Ritze im Stall mit Kork ausgespritzt und
den kompletten Stall geteilt und wenn
wir den startransportieren wollen und
die Hühner auf eine neue Stück Wiese
kommen dann funktioniert das so